24 ultimo club stiamo abbandonando la
casa ci sono una serie sentimenti
contrastanti c'è una parte di noi che
non vedeva l'ora di continuare la parte
di noi che non vedeva l'ora di finire
fanno sul cuore è stata l'esperienza più
tosta e faticosa abbiamo fatto fino ad
oggi in tre anni io torno a casa della
strada come quell'albero come con
l'altro alle palle a pezzi come
prenderti le considerazioni a parte gli
ulti perché sono curioso di sapere in
che modo stiamo tutti 4 mi stendo questo
momento le mie non ce la facevo più
credo che mi farò almeno cinque giorni a
casa a piani o come mi dispiace lasciare
questa casa piangendo ha molta dritte mi
sono vestito bene per l'occasione che
escono di galera
quindi tutti contenti che finalmente la
caldo finalmente quel pezzo era
essenziale ci serviva e stato uno delle
strutture è meglio riuscite per quanto
mi riguarda sono i fari delistato
togliendo l'albero prima che sia natale
a e vennero ragazzi veramente rendere
conto quanto ci siamo impegnati
quest'anno per riuscire a stare su
youtube sutri cercando allo stesso tempo
di sistemare tutti quanti problemi
tecnici è stato devastante e ragazzi vi
prego riprende temi quello dicono e
quello nego mai più così
mai più sono diventato vecchio la nostra
cena di natale sarà la più bella la più
dura con test cioè la lucania menù è
nascosto riservato che the money to è
pure parlando come te cucina 9 martera a
puntare contraggono richiamo 400 euro di
crudi ha soppresso salviamo il nostro
vecchio diventano di fiducia tutto crudo
dentici e crudo mamma mia il 25 lo stavo
su una tanto ne accetto tutti i vini
biologici che ho preso io vini bp che vi
sarebbe il sole cambiano colore omega
male utili perché vivo dentro il
cruciale alla micro buccia non è un vino
motto è un vino vivo comprarmi una casa
con piscina quando voi sarà benvenuta ma
non è che niente niente invece questa è
una barca the money un cazzo sto da solo
a casa ma poi signor green ciò i poveri
non posso venire in meno di gianmarco
tutto è diverso perché voi secondo me
farete la porcata di crudi e cose così
loro invece faranno una voce nato seruci
nato serio
no no loro faranno la porcata di pastoni
ma pazzoni paste sfoglie la sanzioni
fatte vagito a dolci così gianluigi farà
tutte così sciccosissima di classe oggi
e mi sorella che sarà da due giorni
prima si avvantaggia le preparazioni
parte poi questa campagna e crudi quindi
dovete quasi niente come vengono fatte a
parte la materia prima che ci abbiamo
noi è indiscussa discussa perché noi
siamo più ricchi di te siamo più
arricchiti che perché noi abbiamo fatto
il film siamo più ricchi di te è meglio
di di sentire perché gianmarco lavora
per una grande grande avvio cui capitano
di ventura direttore direttore ma tutti
ma lei manca ma non è tipo una settimana
da dio faccio tutto io ti dico soltanto
grecia la firma lì accanto a te ma si
sente pianissimo hai messo la mano
microfono ma lei ma la mano dar
microfono che dico soltanto che stanno a
fa la spina di natale e gianmarco ha
detto che giulia sta facendo tipo i
ravioli con il polpo dentro che ha detto
che c'era un per culo a cucina io ho
detto dove famosa mappa la cena del
natale che non c'è paragone
quindi nulla di elaborato a livello di
qualità tecnica di rompiamo il culo a
mani basse nano giulia animali qualità
tecnica ho sentito il suo menù è follia
è una maggiore ad almeno diva giorgione
ordinata dalla curia fa in cottura
lentissima poi grigliato con burro
regatare pane roba così che tentata
all'acqua che praticamente ci scappa il
morto che traccia un preservativo da me
lo tieni la via marina si vuole portare
tutte le ducati nella sua casa ragazzi
quanto ti manca che un appuntamento
dallo psichiatra
io vorrei farti vedere quindi stiamo
togliendo per lo streaming
faccio un giro per far vedere le cose
che abbiamo questo quello questo gatti
un altro inferno questo come quello
anche troppo
abbiamo una valigia testa quindi anzi
onesti in cucina odio c'è un gatto nel
secchio dell'immondizia come sempre
verso questo questo questo è quello
quello poi dire presto questo non finirà
mai
abbiamo creato questo punto di accumulo
è delirio è il delirio e tutto tale in
italia non ce la faremo chiede a
piangere regala dove avete vi sono
scatole nuovo messo qui la tendenza rega
e sicuro troviamo rigano di fine blog
arrivato gambetta umberto ok quindi gli
effetti siete voi
valentina un difficile molto difficile
coraggio da vendere vedo è anche un
cervello niente male per rifare
valentina
il comico si sa la linea vorrei donare
un palo portatile di legno elfico per
rallegrare le atmosfere più cupe
volteggiando su e giù come una colomba
ma la nostra forest è stata battuta
aregai a non l'avevo visto non ci credo
neanche cos'è
a enrico vorrei donare una stecca di
legno antico indistruttibile per gli
occhiali
ecco un mini che perché quella non
allora la targhetta ogni giorno si potrà
sbagliare e pregare se stesso pazzesco
vogliamo cominciare a produrle in serie
a era meglio mezzo per rendere felici
tutti gli italiani allora a gabriele
senza velo glabro è sempre nudo donna il
trofeo della prorompenza per ricordare a
tutti lo sforzo prorompente che ci è
voluto per sganciare bombe detriti
organici del mare accanto alla fanciulla
indifesa che stava felice credendo di
essere una sirena ma la povera fanciulla
indifesa
mi piace molto come scrivono e scrive
per davvero è un poeta
l'artista non andava bene ragazzi pezzi
con il mantello della roma sembra un po
gaston a gianmarco vorrei donare un
cuore ma non solo il mago di oz
purtroppo quindi trasformerò nel green
però vabbè sei simpatico anche tu e ti
meriti un regalo più bello
infine al caposquadra il nord la mente
di tutto a the good will vabbè è capito
la mia mente mio ingegno si sono fusi a
quello di el favella edelfa lamiere fare
una cosa di unia sono solamente
distrutta qualcosa che spero conserverà
i cali secoli a venire si perché noi
sagittari siamo eterni siamo capaci di
rimanere nelle anime di tutti a maggio
cliccate sagittale
[Musica]
checa laccio d'amore a voi a con cui non
ci credo no ragazzi allora ragazzino ha
scalato bellissimo cavolo bellissimo
piccolo forziere gentile ragazzi qua
sotto vi lasciamo il link di un battito
sempre da anche voi qual cosina custom
menna sono solo per voi
roberto e grazie a me
poi qua di rientro guardate che c'è qui
ma è un saluto sia in gg
c'è mancato alcune ragazze rischiate
purtroppo stavo lavorando anzi per
fortuna però mi sono schiantato da
quella casa dei matti venite a roma
stiamo preparando una zucca per questa
sera ma già questura ma prepara e si
comincia adesso per liberare un po il
frigo che cela bacchio bene domani che
vedrà nano scorfano che è stato già
stilettata e tutte le del dis che le
teste sono entrati dentro per questo
meraviglioso guarda sto mettendo il
succo delle vongole
mamma mia adesso si comincia a dar
sempre più sapore momento bagnetto
momento bagnetto adesso andiamo ad
aggiungere mamma mia
proprio calma senza fretta con molta
dedizione questi batteri da solo e
questo gli ho detto una mano e aveva una
mano piccola purtroppo facciamo crudo ed
accompagneremo con quota mole tutto pane
carasau ragazzi meravigliosi finalmente
ragazzi a casa finalmente a casa
crozza che dici come jenna trilla fab
ciao a tutti vi faccio vedere se
mangiamo stasera o andata ad un cazzo
eccoci la nostra quota di stasera giulia
gabriele che sta scottate dice che ci
rompono il culo gabriele non sa fare
neanche un noto foto maggio ma questa tu
lo sai che pure doveva fare una uguale
su cui c'e ma al partito malissimo
distruggere nascondiamo adesso ragazzini
che bello
il buon natale un cazzo cazzo
a quando un cazzo e quantità di video pa
e siamo in quattro a carbone possiamo
essere in due in 5 10 20 ma sempre
manciata gli siamo vicini al è micidiale
se vuoi russo definisce così chiamati a
mamma prima di affiancare posso certo
una cosa che siamo già fatti uno
spumante 46 muove nervi a parte il fatto
che sta registrando dati di van
questo facciamo a capire marito con
fritturina camere che abilita il pazzo
del male distaccata ragazzi tante ombre
e finiva scritto veramente nostra tanti
auguri ragazzi braccio e ora vediamo che
sai fare gabriele parmigiana di spada
polpo grigliato burrata i pomodorini
confitta tardi tonno crostini di polenta
fritta con uova di pesce spada e baccalà
mantecato mammamia questo è l'antipasto
sono commosso giovanni fattori hai fatto
i botti karakuri arrivi già mi chiedi di
kolin competente di gianluigi non potrà
tenere testa ma non gravissimo infatti
lo capisco gabriele vostra
questo discorso non levare direttamente
col mio competitor diretto ecco il primo
primo raviolo ripieno di ricotta e
limone e contenuto con burro
aromatizzato di alici e prezzemolo
bottarga in tavola io faccio un giretto
e augusto velo aggiungete certe di
[Musica]
giuliano cazzola gioia e infine
calamarata allo scoglio può a natale
ragazze natale ciao ragazzi siamo
all'apertura del vino mammalian
equiparate quant'è bella mamma questo
vestito natalizio il maglione di harry
[Risate]
non era sua strada questo è un metro di
biscotti con metodi begotti 5 questi due
non fanno altro che baciarsi e ballare
c'è mamma mia quanto amore in questa
casa da me e da nemo tanti auguri di
buon natale
comunque i ragazzi mi mancate tutti
tantissimo ma fortuna che già impazza e
che piaceranno sicuramente calmati con
queste cose meravigliate con mio
fratello distante volevo fare i miei
migliori auguri di buon natale a tutti
quanti soprattutto a chi
storia per cause di forza maggiore che
in parte solo perno di una folle di un
posto meraviglioso dormi bene
in questa serata che mi passò con guido
che col club posso dire potrebbe essere
forse una delle più tristi di quest'anno
non lo trovo più celeri quest'anno
perché la libertà del positano
comprendere i miei familiari è un
qualcosa di meraviglioso
sono dell'idea che o tutto o niente
quindi video rifare natali con solamente
una parte di loro mi avrebbe annichilito
quindi meglio in compagnia dello zoo che
ormai abita la mia casa
detto ciò per concludere in questo blog
ma se ringraziato tutti quanti perché ci
avete seguito che minacciando
soprattutto orale che ha fatto un lavoro
meraviglioso con montagnino stando cd è
vero non so come ringraziando anche
tutte le persone che sono social viola
quindi i ragazzi abbonati che stanno sul
disco ma soprattutto i moderatori che
sono pazzeschi ora tutti quanti ragazzi
spero che questo 2021 possa portarci
pensa con i cose bellissime 2020 è stato
un anno di profonda riflessione mi son
trattamenti del caso di riflettere
quindi sarebbe bellissimo riuscire a
tornare a vivere normalmente con da
queste ore sta sud a cadere presidiamo
sempre a trovare gli auguro cammino di
trovare la loro marita in questa
normalità che inizia con la pa no perché
comunque una lita detto ciò un bacio a
tutti quanti non ci arriveremo domani
alle 14 i dati sui giusto il tempo per
potersi rimettere in piedi goderci un
pochino questa vacanza che ripartiamo
con i blog che ripartiamo con i video
che riportiamo con tutto quanto vi
voglio bene
un bacio e già mi mancano tutti quanti
ragazzi che stavano con me nella casa
non è vero ma era carino dirlo ciao